[Music]
foreign
the trouble is not in dying for a friend
but in finding a friend worth dying for
never allow someone to be your priority
while allowing yourself to be their
option
never put off till tomorrow what may be
done day after tomorrow just as well
[Music]
the fear of death follows from the fear
of life
a man who lives fully is prepared to die
at any time
[Music]
truth is Stranger Than Fiction but it is
because fiction is obliged to stick to
possibilities truth isn't
classic a book which people praise and
don't read
courage is resistance to fear Mastery of
fear not absence of fear
everyone is a moon and has a dark side
which he never shows to anybody
[Music]
to get the full value of joy you must
have someone to divide it with
[Music]
is a language which the deaf can hear
and the blind can see
a lie can travel Halfway Around the
World while the truth is putting on its
shoes
it's easier to fool people than to
convince them that they are being fooled
the man with a new idea is a crank until
the idea succeeds
[Music]
all you need in this life is ignorance
and confidence then success is sure
the lack of money is the root of all
evil
[Music]
20 years from now you will be more
disappointed by the things you didn't do
than by the things you did do
a man's character may be learned from
the adjectives which he habitually uses
in conversation
foreign
we are all in the gutter but some of us
are looking at the stars
wisdom is the reward you get for a
lifetime of listening when you would
rather have talked
[Music]
it is better to deserve honors than not
have them than to have them and not
deserve them
the more I learn about people the more I
like my dog
travel is the only thing in the world
that makes you richer by buying
be careful when reading Health books a
typo can cost you your life
[Music]
people who have their own grief know how
to comfort others
the worst loneliness is when a person is
uncomfortable with himself
[Music]
my books are water the books of great
Geniuses are wine
everyone drinks water
[Music]
it is worth giving your word that you
will not do anything
as you will certainly want to do it
[Music]
good friends good books and a sleeping
conscience are the ideal life
[Music]
a person cannot be satisfied with life
if he is dissatisfied with himself
forgiveness is the fragrance that a
violet leaves on the boot that trampled
it
let's thank the fools without them it
would be difficult for the others to
succeed
the right to stupidity is one of the
guarantees of free personal development
[Music]
the dog you treat will never bite you
this is the main difference between an
animal and a human
[Music]
the truth should be served the way a
coat is served not thrown in the face
like a wet towel
children and fools always tell the truth
friend is with you when you're wrong
when you are right everyone will be with
you
summer is a time of the year when it is
very hot to do things that it was very
cold to do in winter
[Music]
nothing needs fixing more than other
people's habits
be virtuous and you will be lonely
[Music]
we are all made from the same dough and
a rather poor quality
grief must be experienced alone but joy
in order to fully know must be shared
with another person
[Music]
pessimism is just a word that the
faint-hearted call wisdom
the people are the only critic whose
judgment has value
a person is ready to do a lot to awaken
love but will decide on anything to
cause Envy
most writers consider truth to be their
most valuable asset that's why they use
it so sparingly
[Music]
we recognize people by their heart not
by their eyes or intellect
friendship is such a sacred sacred
feeling that you can keep it for life as
long as you don't try to ask for a loan
life would be so much happier if you
were born at ajd and gradually reached
18.
when you remember that we're all crazy
the strange things in life disappear and
everything makes sense
[Music]
if you don't know what to say tell the
truth
it's your facts first then you can
distort them as you please
foreign
ER is an acid that can do more harm to
the vessel in which it is stored than to
anything on which it is poured
clothes make the man naked people have
little or no influence on society
[Music]
there are lies damn lies and statistics
the first of April is the day we
remember what we are the other 364 days
of the year
[Music]
many a small thing has been made large
by the right kind of advertising
when people do not respect us we are
sharply offended yet in his private
heart no man much respects himself
everything has its limit iron ore cannot
be educated into gold
noise proves nothing often a hen who has
merely laid an egg cackles as if she had
laid an asteroid
a man is never more truthful than when
he acknowledges himself a liar
the man who does not read has no
advantage over the man who cannot read
a cat that once sat on a hot stove will
never sit on it again
nor on a cold stove
there are no people more rude than
overly refined natures
laws control the lesser man right
conduct controls the greater one
[Music]
Patriot the person who can holler the
loudest without knowing what he is
hollering about
[Music]
if man could be crossed with the cat it
would improve man but deteriorate the
cat
[Music]